saturday evening at a greek restaurant
on Berlin's bustling shopping street the
kurfürstendamm the guests dig into their
Satsuki and knock back Guzzo many our
regular customers here on a first-name
basis with the owner dimitrios carefully
this has lived in Germany for 38 years
Matt he's in constant contact with his
family in Greece minus those for my
sister moved to Berlin a year ago
because there wasn't any job in Greece
my brother-in-law lost his job at the
harvest so they came to Berlin we help
them find an apartment and a job and now
they're doing fine no one here is
quarreling about Greece's 316 billion
euros of debt instead they enjoy a taste
of the Mediterranean in Berlin Greek
food is delicious we weren't completely
thrilled with Greece it's really a shame
in roads you could see the lack of money
there are lots of shops that were closed
but the people don't wear it on their
sleeves but no one here is thrilled
either with Greece's attitude towards
its debts
ding commander he liked when I am I
ought to put his stuff to it and not
encourage it the money that's already
gone there hasn't been used wisely
finish move on I or what I'm gonna get
when I borrow money I have to pay it
back to and we pay our taxes but you
tried out will destroy the European
Central Bank's aid package isn't popular
still dimitrios has hopes for a better
future of course I wish things will
improve for people the tax system will
be better that people can find a job
greece's high unemployment has to be
brought down cuz they be filled some
guests danced the shitake at a
neighboring table Greeks and Germans get
along fine if the Greeks would economize
a bit I think that would be an order if
they reached a consensus yep I end us
we're celebrating life and since life is
expensive and we're paying for the south
then at least we should celebrate
nothing can spoil a party mood and here
at least the Germans are happy to foot
the bill